BRIAN MOROZ: Hello, and welcome
to our fifth and final
installment so far of
the Creative Sandbox
Live Hangout Series.
We have a little bit of
a special treat today.
We're going to start with
Goodby, who will be seen via
Hangouts, but we actually have
McCann in the house sitting
right next to me, that you
can't see quite yet,
but you will soon.
So this is truly live.
My name is Brian Moroz.
I work with Creative Agencies
here at Google.
If you haven't joined any of
these before, you're going to
learn about a couple of really
fantastic uses of Google
technology.
Today's focus is on Geoproducts,
and I'm going to
introduce now my colleague Josh,
who is out in Mountain
View, who is a Geoproducts
expert.
Josh?
JOSH LIVNI: Hi, folks,
and thank you.
So I'm Josh Livni.
I'm part of our Maps Developer
Relations Team, and we're
basically [INAUDIBLE]
Maps platform [INAUDIBLE]
Geoproducts [INAUDIBLE] is
accessible and easy to use by
third parties [INAUDIBLE], and
all the developers who would
want to use Maps [INAUDIBLE].
So that includes chatting with
people, supporting them
online, making [INAUDIBLE]
examples are useful, and
hopefully inspiring
[INAUDIBLE] people who have
a nice story to tell.
[INAUDIBLE] projects
like [INAUDIBLE]
it's a lot of really exciting
[INAUDIBLE]
different angle [INAUDIBLE].
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
And so having Josh on the
line means two things.
Josh can ask questions of the
folks on the call, but more
importantly, the agencies who
have worked with the Maps
products, please feel free to
ask anything you'd like of
Josh, demand things,
request things.
So that's why he's here.
No need to be shy.
So with that, let's go ahead
and take a look at the work
that Goodby did.
We'll take a look at a video,
and then we'll have an
introduction round and start
asking some questions.
Oh, which video, I'm
being asked?
Hold on.
This is live.
So Goodby, if you guys
could tell us what
we're seeing here.
ANDERS GUSTAFSSON: It should
be the back bridges
walk-through and this is
basically just [INAUDIBLE]
and you see that snake of
bridges, and how you added a
bridge using Google Maps,
and also, [INAUDIBLE]
snake, you can see the user's
social media accounts and what
they logged in [INAUDIBLE]
or Twitter or Facebook.
And that should be up.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yep, so we just saw
a series of bridges being
built, and the total length of
the bridges as it was added.
So first of all, let's go ahead
and introduce the folks
from Goodby who are online.
Can you guys just introduce
yourself, and let us know what
role you play at the agency?
ANDERS GUSTAFSSON: Well, I can
start, because I talked
[INAUDIBLE] the demo
you just saw.
My name is Anders Gustafsson.
I'm a Creative Director
at Goodby.
I work across the agency, but I
worked on this project with
the rest of the team.
Great.
HANNA WITTMARK: My
name is Hanna.
I'm an art director
here at Goodby.
GRAHAM LEWIS: Graham Lewis,
copywriter at Goodby across
accounts, and was lucky enough
to work on this one.
MARGARET BRETT-KEARNS: And I'm
Margaret Brett-Kearns, and I'm
the Interactive Producer
on this project.
And we also actually,
maybe Michael, you
can introduce yourself.
So this is the famous
[INAUDIBLE], and they were the
developers of this.
MICHAEL: Hi guys.
I'm Michael, and I'm the
Interactive Director at Famous.
BRANDON: And I'm Brandon,
and I'm the lead
developer on the project.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right, so we
have the whole gang there, it
sounds like.
Let me ask you guys just
initially, where did
the idea come from?
What was the seed of the idea?
And how did you guys work
through it and come to this
final piece, which is almost
like an art piece of sorts?
Where did it generate,
and how did it build?
ANDERS GUSTAFSSON: Well, I'll
just kick this off, and then
Hanna and Graham can fill in.
I think we got some partnerships
with Google, like
[INAUDIBLE], and we're always
looking at new and interesting
technology.
I think in this case, it was
just super relevant because
the Golden Gate Bridge 75th
anniversary, and we wanted
everyone in the world to
be able to participate.
So the Maps API, it's just such
a great platform now that
everyone uses, almost on a daily
basis, so it made total
sense to do something
based on this API.
And Hanna and Graham can talk
some more about the idea and
how that came to be.
GRAHAM LEWIS: Yeah, kind of
going off of what Anders was
saying with really wanting
something that could go across
all these different types
social media, because
obviously, the big thing for
us was the possibility of
really wanting everyone to
participate, even if they
weren't as savvy with different
things online.
So [INAUDIBLE]
for us was [INAUDIBLE] that was
familiar, and really was
able to bring people together
and allow anyone to
participate.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
So it sounds like it started
from the idea of the bridge
itself, then moved into the
technology that people use
very commonly, and then the
concept of the social element,
a lot of people to kind of play
together, was the direction.
Is that accurate?
ANDERS GUSTAFSSON: Yeah.
HANNA WITTMARK: And also, when
we started to do research
about bridges, it felt pretty
natural that bridges were made
to bring people together, and
today we have the social
media, and it's like
the bridges
today across the world.
BRIAN MOROZ: Right, as a
metaphor, but also as a
physical object, and also as a
digital object that you can
then start to combine
and play with.
So let me ask you guys on the
developmental front, the idea
seems pretty clear and it
seems like one that once
you're hit with it, it seems
so natural and easy to
understand.
But on the technical side, it's
actually patching things
together, being able to connect
both the people
socially, as well as build the
bridge physically as an object
that you're seeing
on the screen.
How did that process go?
Was it fairly smooth sailing?
Were there certain technical
hurdles that you
guys had to deal with?
Did you already have a lot of
experience with mapping
applications?
How did that work?
MICHAEL: So it was definitely
a challenge.
Sorry.
It was definitely a challenge
from the beginning, figuring
out how we were going
to get all of these
bridges to line up.
We kind of prototyped it using
just paper at first, just to
figure out how the line crosses
through the tile, and
how we were going to get all
these different lines going in
different directions
to kind of line up
and form the bridge.
Luckily, during the prototyping
phase, Brandon was
actually able to come up with
a system for actually lining
these up and creating that
snake, that smooth,
never-ending snake.
BRANDON: Yeah.
So basically, what we determined
was [INAUDIBLE],
you can use two points and have
Google Maps draw a line
through those two points, that
line will always go through
the center of the image that
you request from Google.
And so that leads us to
basically four types of tiles,
bridge tiles, that can
be determined.
[INAUDIBLE]
basically two types of bridges
that can be determined, and so
certain bridges cannot be
overlapped on certain other
bridges, so we had to determine
which bridges can
and cannot overlap.
So you have a Type One bridge
that goes like that, and a
Type Two bridge that
goes like this.
These can go and touch each
other, no problem.
[INAUDIBLE] a Type Three
bridge that goes this
direction, with a Type Four
direction, a Type Four bridge
cannot be overlapped with Type
Three bridge, [INAUDIBLE] see
where we cut off part of the
bridge, and so we can't
allow that.
So those are the rules
that they basically
figure out and solve.
BRIAN MOROZ: And did you guys do
that essentially in house,
or did you have--
just out of my own curiosity,
did you guys work with folks
like Josh at Google, or do
you have your own ways of
figuring that out?
MICHAEL: So we did a bit of
investigation on our own at
the outset, just kind of
gleaning what we could from
the documentation and the
APIs, and just kind of
experimenting during the
prototyping phase.
And then later on, once we had
more in-depth questions, being
able to speak with someone like
Josh at Google was kind
of critical for us to get past
certain hurdles, like for
example, the zoom level.
BRIAN MOROZ: Gotcha.
And the reason I ask that is
certain people over the last
week, some have worked heavily
with Google, some have just
been like, nope, the
documentation was there for
us, we figured it out,
we had it done.
So it's just interesting to
hear from circumstance to
circumstance, how things
got done when you
actually hit that wall.
So I have one more question,
then I'll turn it over to Josh
to see if he has any questions
for you guys.
I guess my final question is,
how did you determine who at
the agency was going to come
together to work on this?
So you have a lot of diverse
roles here on the call.
I imagine there are people
who are not on the
call who were involved.
How did you put that
team together?
ANDERS GUSTAFSSON: Well, I
mean, the bridge, it's a
client that JSP had been working
with for a long, long
time, and Rich Silverstein was
very involved with the city
and the bridge and the
national parks.
So it's basically a
pro bono project.
And whenever you get a pro bono
project, the way you put
the team together is you try
to find the creatives that
really have got the energy,
and they want to work with
this, and they really feel like
this is something that
they want to get involved in.
It's kind of almost determined
by who really wants to do it.
I think there's some people
missing from the team right
now, and I don't think that it
was necessarily a traditional
creative team, in the sense that
you have one writer, and
one art director, and one
designer, and so forth.
It was just a bunch of people
that really wanted to do
something cool for the
bridge, and felt the
love for this project.
That's how it turned out.
BRIAN MOROZ: Interesting.
So it was definitely a
nontraditional team
formatting, but obviously,
it was successful.
So always good to see that.
Josh, did you have any questions
for these guys?
How they did it, any of the
technological stuff, just
anything generally for them?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
Well first of all, we chatted
quite a few times.
I have to say, it's really
nice to see you guys in
person, [INAUDIBLE] faces,
that is, rather
than on just email.
We had a lot of great
conversations, and the main
thing that I enjoyed was just
the crazy ideas that were
coming through [INAUDIBLE]
people out there.
I remember there was an idea of
having people actually draw
[INAUDIBLE] in Google Street
View, then they would be
[INAUDIBLE].
How could we get that
live, [INAUDIBLE]?
All kinds of really
great stuff.
I guess my main question
[INAUDIBLE], I'd be curious if
there's features that could
have been in the API that
would have made your life
easier, or other things that
we could do.
It's easier for agencies like
yourselves to dive in and
[INAUDIBLE]
things you want.
It's not just putting markers
on [INAUDIBLE], kind of a
canvas [INAUDIBLE].
BRANDON: One thing that would
have been really helpful is if
Google had an API to pull
bridges, essentially.
That was one of the main
challenges, because Google and
Margaret had [INAUDIBLE]
a list of all possible bridges,
and there was no way
to do that.
One thing we looked into was
doing that list of bridges for
the National Traffic Safety
Board, or something like that,
but that turned out
to be not really
feasible in this situation.
So definitely, getting a list of
bridges and other types of
roads would be a nice
feature for the
Google Maps API to have.
MICHAEL: It's kind of a
specialized use case, but I
think for us, it might
have made things
a little bit easier.
MARGARET BRETT-KEARNS: Yeah.
I actually agree with that.
It was one of the challenges
we had on the creative side
when we were thinking about,
how are people going to use
this, and we wanted it to be
something that was easy for
people to find a bridge without
having to use too many
brain cells.
But it's actually turned out to
be an interesting series of
months on this project to see
how the bridge has evolved and
how it's traveled through
different countries, and we
seem to be having,
for example, a
burst now in Russia.
There are a lot of Russians
who are participating, and
we've had bursts in
Southeast Asia.
We started with a giant
burst in Brazil.
So maybe in the end, not having
that list of bridges
wasn't a terrible thing, but
it would have been nice to
have it to begin with.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, that's
really good feedback.
I think more generally,
providing people more in-depth
access to the features that
underlie the map is a comment
that we get quite a
bit for all kinds
of different reasons.
People are interested in more
than just, say, for example,
places, we expose
that [INAUDIBLE]
businesses and other
[? entities ?] around you.
So maybe yours is a specialized
case, but it's
definitely a good thing to
request, so good call.
ANDERS GUSTAFSSON: I've got
a question for you, Josh.
Have we actually created a big
database of bridges for you
now that you will use
in the future?
Because it feels like we've
actually done the
labeling for you.
MALE SPEAKER: It's for sale.
It's very inexpensive.
We can make a trade
down the line.
Yeah, I haven't actually
looked at that.
That's an interesting other
point, which is you guys are
storing all of your data
on App Engine.
You guys created a fairly
straightforward but really
nice little App Engine site
where people [INAUDIBLE]
and metadata [INAUDIBLE]
stored.
Obviously, we don't look in
there, but it is a useful data
set to have.
It's an interesting thing to
think about, when your project
is finished, is there ways you
could make any kind of use of
that information.
BRIAN MOROZ: Cool.
GRAHAM LEWIS: Another thing that
had come up, one of the
other art directors,
[INAUDIBLE]
that worked on this project with
us had noticed that one
hurdle that we had was figuring
out how we could
legally use some of the images
from Google Maps itself,
because there is some variance
just in terms of usage and
cropping and rotating and
things like that.
Looking at really clear cut
rules for usage, or maybe
seeing about [INAUDIBLE],
because I know that, I think,
certain areas, the images are
owned by different sections,
which is kind of like the
universal [INAUDIBLE].
Having it be unified
like that.
BRIAN MOROZ: That's an
interesting point, and that's
something that we run across,
or at least I do when I work
with agencies somewhat
frequently.
It's not even so much, can you
do it, as, is the policy
accepting of that usage?
So that's a great point, making
that stuff crystal
clear and very cut and dry.
So lots of great information.
Thank you guys.
If you don't mind, please hang
out for a little bit longer so
that we can all ask questions of
everyone at the end of the
session here today.
But from here, we're going to
go ahead, and we'll switch
over to McCann.
So let's take a look at
is their reel, and
then we'll jump in.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: This is to
keep the bears away.
Oh, look at that.
[MUSIC - FLEET FOXES,
"RAGGED WOOD"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
BRIAN MOROZ: OK, so going
from bridges to trails.
I have our friends from McCann
sitting here with me in studio
live today.
I'm a little disappointed the
didn't bring us a bear stick
to keep the bears away,
but I'm going to let
that one go for now.
Can you guys just give a quick
introduction and tell us who
you are, what you do
at the agency?
BRAD: Hi, I'm Brad.
I'm a developer at [INAUDIBLE],
and I helped lead
the project on the
development.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: I'm
Catherine Patterson, I'm the
Executive Producer at McCann
for the Integrated Group.
MATT: And I'm Matt
[INAUDIBLE].
I'm a Group Creative
Director at McCann.
BRIAN MOROZ: So I'm going to ask
you guys the same question
that I initially asked of
the bridge project.
Where did the idea come from?
I mean, clearly the client in
this case is not a pro bono,
this is something to do with
nature, it's a granola bar, so
you have that kind of natural
element, but you guys went
somewhere really unique
and really specific.
How did that happen?
MATT: You know, I always start
out answering this question by
almost giving credit to Nature
Valley, just from the
standpoint that they do a thing
once a year called Bold
Experiments where they
essentially put out to their
partner agencies this sort of
grand mission of, give us
something from a marketing
standpoint that isn't in the
regular calendar year of
marketing, and is something, a
bigger, sort of interesting
notion that can live in a
bigger space and in
a bigger way.
So I think we were lucky from
the standpoint that Nature
Valley was on the forefront of
marketing and wanting to do
interesting and cool stuff.
So for us, it was a bold
experiment that was kind of
put to us, and this was kind
of the solution that
we came back with.
There was a number of brands
that they asked for Bold
Solutions for, and Nature
Valley was one of them.
BRIAN MOROZ: And what led to
the idea of mapping these
trails specifically?
MATT: So in terms of coming to
that conclusion of mapping
trails, it was almost a little
bit, it seemed like kind of a
natural progression for us.
Nature Valley has had, for the
past three years, a great
relationship with the
National Parks.
They do a program called
Preserve the Parks, and it
seemed like a natural
fit for us.
If they're doing a Preserve the
Parks program, why would
we not actually digitally start
to preserve these parks?
So the notion of marrying Street
View with what we're
calling Trail View seemed
like a very natural
progression for us.
It was ultimately fun for us to
go out and do, and seemed
very cool for us.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah, it
looked like fun.
Those camera units looked
crazy, like satellites,
basically, on top of these
guys' backpacks.
Super, super cool stuff.
So on the technical front, what
were the challenges that
you guys found?
What was the basic technology
that you laid down to use, and
where did you kind of come into
areas where you stumbled
and overcame them?
BRAD: Right.
So I've used Google Maps a bunch
on a couple of projects
beforehand, and right around
October of last year, Street
View become actually enabled
with WebGL, and it
gave us a 3D view.
And that was actually
exposing the API, so
I didn't look back.
I just went ahead and selected
that as a platform of choice.
And then the second hurdle was
basically processing all the
data, all the footage.
We made a little infographic
of this stuff.
We basically had 12 terabytes of
video and six gigabytes of
GPS data, not all of which
was necessarily clean and
accurate, given to satellite
coverage on
the trails and parks.
So just mapping those trails,
looking at them every day for
almost six months,
was a [INAUDIBLE]
experience.
BRIAN MOROZ: Get to know
them very well.
You don't have to
ever walk them.
BRAD: Well, I have to
just go there now
and see if it's true.
MATT: [INAUDIBLE]
them virtually.
BRIAN MOROZ: Very cool.
And how did the interactive
process work when it came
from, here's our ideas,
OK great.
Now, here's the technical piece,
now here are the people
we're hiring to walk
the trails.
Who was involved at one time?
How tight was that?
MATT: I'll turn it over to Cat,
but that, for me, was the
super interesting part, just
the notion that we can have
this great idea and turn it over
to someone like Cat, and
watch her actually figure out
how to do this, which is the
really difficult part.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: One of the
things that we focused on,
obviously, it takes
a lot of different
disciplines and teams.
So the first order of business
was, who as the field team is
going to be capable of going out
and capturing hundreds and
hundreds of miles?
Who is our home team, who will
be adequately trained to
participate in those hundreds
and hundreds of miles, in
terms of capture?
So we obviously partnered
with [INAUDIBLE]
first as our design team,
development team.
Our next order of business was
looking for the appropriate
field team, the production team,
and then looking at the
camera technologies that we were
going to be implementing
on the trails.
So we needed to look at
different things, we needed to
look at elevation, we needed
to look at temperatures.
We got into some discovery
questions around, what happens
if you have this camera rig on
a human body and you walk him
into the Grand Canyon and he's
been there for 12 hours, at
what point does your camera
equipment start to
malfunction?
So we had all kinds of really
interesting, logical,
operational testing questions.
And then we needed to look at,
how does this really work as
an army coming together with
all of these elements?
We're going to go out to these
very remote locations, which
means we need a SWAT team on the
ground out there capable
of capturing very aggressive
content.
We're going to bring
that content back.
We need an unbelievably gifted
development team and post
processing team able to take
that content, process it, and
build it into a technology
platform.
And then obviously, a big design
element was also a big
part of the platform is for us
enabling people to experience
very, very high end visual
POIs, Points of Interest,
inside these trail
environments.
So the camera, the design
direction in terms of
photography--
which was led by Your Majesty,
by [? Yann's ?]
Carlson, who's their
ECD there--
was very much focused on, how
do we give you a very deep,
immersive experience of these
POIs and bring all those
things together into
the platform.
So it's a lot of elements coming
together, but it made
it very fun to work on.
BRIAN MOROZ: Yeah, quite
a lot of elements.
So a quick reminder to the folks
who are watching this
live, if you have questions,
you'll be seeing a link
popping up now and again that
you can enter questions into
our Moderator tool.
So you can ask anything of
either agency, or of Josh.
And speaking of Josh, Josh, what
are your questions for
these guys on this application
that they created, this whole
immersive world that
they built?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, well first,
it's a really beautiful site.
I think it's such a nice idea,
and put together so well and
so smoothly.
I think it looks great.
I'll cheat and use the same
question I had before, which
is, you obviously had a lot of
moving parts, one of them was
integrating with the API, and
most of the time, when we see
people do what we call
custom [INAUDIBLE]
within the API, it's just
a few snapshots, maybe
[INAUDIBLE]
business, or if it's a hike, it
would be one or two shots
along the hike where they
have [INAUDIBLE]
interactive.
But you guys went to a
whole nother level.
And I'd be curious to know if
the API was there for you, or
other things we could do to make
it easier and better for
the next super exciting thing
that you guys want to
[INAUDIBLE].
BRAD: Yes, definitely.
I mean, the API is constantly
evolving.
I actually haven't looked at the
recent docs, but I'm sure
there are a couple of features
that are currently enabled.
But when I started, I was having
a pretty interesting
translation problem between
designs and what
could the API offer.
And I ran into a couple of
very technical, specific
hurdles, [INAUDIBLE] your
strokes on Path, or spatially
putting markers in the 3G view
so you can pinpoint mountains,
or really accurately pinpoint
points of interest and place
them there.
I think we've had a couple
discussions, and this seems to
be community-wide requests and
features that are of interest,
and in Phase Two, hopefully
we can tackle this stuff.
But producing a quality design
like the one we did with all
the moving parts was
very challenging.
It was a big integration process
between adding custom
menus and elevation charts,
so it functions as both a
navigational device
and it gives you
an idea of the topology.
There's so many features that
we can actually keep asking
you guys for, but we pushed it
to the limit, and I think we
did a pretty good job enabling
all these things.
It's pretty massive.
Each trail is about
50,000 frames.
We tried to do an Auto
Play feature.
That's what you guys do, but
you guys seem to have the
secret sauce and we don't,
so hopefully you'll
give it over one day.
Just to be able to cruise along
a trail, just navigating
and seeing all this high res
photography will be fantastic
one day, and I think we're
getting closer with the web
moving forward.
BRIAN MOROZ: Josh,
make that happen.
What was the timeline like for
you guys on this project,
because oftentimes, these things
come up and then--
in this past week when we've
had these Hangout sessions,
I've just been amazed at
how short sometimes
the time frame is.
How was it for this project,
given that it was so
complicated?
MATT: Cat can probably
speak to schedule.
I know it's been almost two
years now since we first
started the project.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: I think
what's really interesting
about a platform like this--
this is obviously a very deep,
integrated platform
development--
is that there are three
timelines, right?
There's a timeline that's an
18-month timeline, and inside
that, we sort of looked
at it as three
marathons with hurdles.
The first was defining the
content that we wanted to
capture and going out and
capturing the content.
The next was bringing it home
and laying out the platform
foundation.
And then really doing the site
build, really doing due
diligence and looking at
editorial and content layers
and making it richer
and deeper.
So from a producing point of
view for our teams, we were
very focused psychologically
on the idea that these were
key markers and that we needed
to get to each one of these
delivery points and then be in
a state of mind to go into
that next platform
development.
But overall, we've been working
on this platform, it
will be two years in February,
and we're continuing to work
on evolving the platform with
stuff that is planned and in
production, and will continue to
pretty much late summer in
the end of 2013.
BRIAN MOROZ: Wow.
So this is a really
long term project.
This is something you guys--
you've used the word "platform"
a few times, and I
think that's a key thing
to bring up.
This wasn't like a campaign,
where you're like, this is
just going to run,
and it's great.
It's a platform that you want
to have that's going to live
for a long period of time, and
that's going to be built on
and changed over time.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: I think
one of the things that is
really important about the way
we approach this work for the
brand, for us as creatives and
producers inside it was
talking about a philosophical
principle that we were going
to do it against many,
many times over.
So it was about connecting
with nature, creating a
platform that allowed people to
experience nature in unique
and evolved ways using these
technologies, and then
building on that and iterating
against that so that the
mandate was always, how do we
enable you and empower you,
whoever you are, to
enjoy nature in
these different ways?
MATT: It was also, I think
building on that, it was
almost a natural for us just
because Nature Valley already
had this kind of ongoing
promise to
these National Parks.
They had this Preserve
the Parks program.
So for us, it was almost like
this was a really great,
creative expression
and extension of
that natural platform.
So the notion of building a
digital expression of that
promise seemed like a really
cool challenge for us.
BRIAN MOROZ: Very, very cool.
And in the video, you notice a
little bit of a social element
to it, and that's just the
magic word for everything
these days.
If you have a client
who doesn't ask for
social, you're like what?
Why?
But the word "social" is
such almost a non-word.
Its definition is so broad as
to be almost meaningless,
depending on the context.
Clearly you have an
element there.
How did you bake
that piece in?
How did you come up with how
that was going to be a social
thing, and then
technologically make it happen?
MATT: I'll start, and then
Cat will jump in.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: Yeah.
MATT: Cat and I do this
all the time.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: Tag team.
MATT: So I think the notion of
adding a piece involving
people was always something that
has been in the back of
our minds, and as Cat was
saying, it was such a daunting
and massive mission to start to
lay the groundwork for the
project and actually physically
go out and capture
for the first round
300-some-plus miles, and
hundreds more that we're adding
on now, that it was
very important for us to get
that groundwork laid.
And we always knew that the
next phase is to actually
bring people.
We have the groundwork laid,
and then you need to invite
people to play and
be a part of it.
So we do have an element of
social where you can send
actual, specific points and
people can jump directly into
360 degree views, and
you can tweet and
Facebook it and stuff.
But I think that's even the
start of our next big
challenge in terms of, how
exactly a much bigger social
layer really lives on the site
and allows people to be a part
of it in a very big way.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: And just
to add to [INAUDIBLE],
philosophically, the idea was,
we are all the stewards and
the preservationists of
this park and this
culture and this heritage.
It is our territory to have
responsibility for that.
Now, we're empowering you to
have community and integrated
community around that, and
following on that, we are
literally charging you with
becoming stewards and
preservationists in your own
right of these national parks.
So these are tools that we're
currently working on in terms
of evolving the platform from
something that's very
immersive and experiential into
tactical and utility-driven in
terms of, here's what you can
now do yourself in this park,
in these regions, as these
communities, to be part of
this incredibly important
cultural heritage that we feel
everyone should be involved in
and engaged with.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
So a couple more questions for
you guys, and then we'll open
it up to any questions
from the folks
who have been watching.
But something that I definitely
need to know.
Were there any bear attacks
during the filming of this, or
were any hikers injured during
the creation of this?
CATHERINE PATTERSON: Ironically,
none of our hikers
were injured or attacked.
We saw many, many
wild animals.
We're obviously rubes,
[? outland ?] rubes going out
into the wilderness, should have
been its own behind the
scenes movie.
But we saw amazing,
amazing wildlife--
snakes, bears, bison--
incredible, incredible nature.
It took us from a place of
braggadocio anxiety into just
having our minds completely
blown.
And for us and for the teams,
having that experience
empirically really made
us understand,
you must be in nature.
We were so blown away by those
types of engagements without
injury that we really were
jazzed about getting people
not just to get into the
platform, but get
out to these parks.
These parks are amazing.
MATT: I think we were all just
really surprised about--
when we finally got out there
and started doing this, I
think we always liked the notion
of this platform, but I
think we were all very surprised
by how much it
actually personally affected us,
being able to actually be
in, as Ken Burns says, America's
greatest idea for as
long as were.
And we were very lucky, and
it was a pretty humbling
experience, actually.
BRIAN MOROZ: Very cool.
All right.
So my last question is,
given the scope of
this kind of a project--
manpower, ideas,
technologically--
I'm going to ask you guys
separately from the creative
ideation putting it all together
standpoint, and then
from the technology standpoint,
and we'll start
with technology.
If you had one piece of advice
to give to anyone who was
trying to do something that was
somehow similar to this
project, what would be the one
thing you should say, just be
aware that you should always
do this, or never try that?
What's the one important thing
you can tell them?
BRAD: If it's a fellow
developer, read the docs
really well.
That's the first thing.
You will discover a lot
of answers there.
And second, I would
say, experiment
and try to poke more.
But I know that the maps, the
API doesn't offer all the
features that we'd like, but I
would say, there's a great
community out there, and if you
keep peeking and pushing,
Google maybe from Mountain View
will respond and give us
some good stuff one day.
BRIAN MOROZ: We'll post Josh's
personal email up
at the end of this.
BRAD: On the other hand, I think
the problem we faced was
just a massive [INAUDIBLE]
of footage, it was really
unconventional.
And I would say, if you can
shoot that much and bring it
back to the lab, that's great,
but take your diligence in
picking the right format, and
be patient in producing the
highest quality imagery, and
then the API will be there to
carry you all the way through.
Just an anecdote.
I mean, if you're actually
wondering what to select, and
this might sound like a plug for
you guys, but we looked at
some other mapping engines, and
most of them worked like a
crab, so you traverse the world
like a crab in 2D view,
and that's not acceptable
anymore these days.
So I encourage everyone
to play with
the maps if you haven't.
I know most of the experiments
are placing markers on a map,
but there's a lot more you can
do, and there's a bunch of
opportunities that are coming up
every day, so keep playing.
BRIAN MOROZ: And one piece of
advice from your guys' side,
from the idea, development,
and production of this?
MATT: Have Cat involved.
No, I mean, the thing that I
was constantly amazed about
was we collectively
as a team--
Leslie Sims, Jason
Schmall and I--
had an idea, and it's one thing
to have an idea, but
then it's completely another
thing just to
watch it come to life.
We had no idea if this was
possible, how to do it, and
just surround yourself with the
best people, and that's
what we did.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: And just
from Production, learning from
Creative and all team
integration.
The best note that we got was in
the cab going to the Great
Smokies on the way out to
the first day of trails.
We were sitting in the back
of the car with Creatives.
And Creatives was like,
you know what I think?
I think you're going to make
the show that you want,
because it's going to get
canceled anyway someday.
So go for broke.
Make exactly the platform that
you want, because sooner or
later, life moves on.
So that was really, for us,
inspiring in terms of being
like, hell yeah, we're
going for it.
We're going to get every hurdle
because we're going to
make it exactly what we want.
So we were very focused on
troubleshooting and problem
solving because we knew exactly
what that show was
that we wanted, just to
use a traditional.
But I would say, go for the big
idea, the big picture, and
be very brave and know that it's
in you and it's in your
teams to accomplish those
things for sure.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great.
We've heard that general
sentiment a lot this week, but
this is the first I've heard
it with the negative
reinforcement of, it's going to
eventually die anyway, so
why not make something
super cool?
MATT: That is the built-in
pessimism of my old partner,
Jason Schmall and I.
BRIAN MOROZ: All right, great.
So thank you guys.
Thanks, everyone, for
being on this call.
I think this was very
illuminating, two totally,
completely different uses of
this technology, both of which
are beautiful and engaging and
shrewdly social, and just
lovely to look at, and very
complicated to make.
So it was great to
have you guys.
Let's take a look at the
questions that have come in.
And anyone who wants to answer
these from any quadrant,
please just jump in.
Let's see.
I'm refreshing my page here.
We have several questions.
So here's one from [INAUDIBLE],
Wisconsin.
As more people interact with
the campaigns, will there
continue to be this same user
experience, or are more
elements being added?
Let's talk about the bridge
project first.
Are you guys going to be adding
to that, or is that
something where it's an art
piece that's just kind of
growing naturally, or are
you going to be adding
functionality?
MARGARET BRETT-KEARNS: At this
point, we're not planning on
adding functionality to it.
The anniversary event was at the
end of May, and it's just
been really interesting to see
how it's traveled around the
globe and grown organically
on its own.
So at this point, we'd love
to optimize some of the
functionality, but it's a pro
bono project, so we're always
in a tight budget situation.
What's been interesting is as
more and more people have
participated and more and more
bridges have been added, we've
had a little bit of slow down in
the experience as a result,
because we're almost a victim
of our own success.
So that would be the one area
that I'd like to see us
improve upon.
BRIAN MOROZ: Right.
And the actual nature
of the project is
it does grow naturally.
It, by its very nature, changes
each day or each week
as people add and build
it further.
And from the trails side, I
think we heard the answer was
essentially, absolutely.
You guys are really looking to
push it and take it further.
So great question.
Any parks or trails in
particular that stood out to
you city slickers that you'd
recommend visiting?
MATT: I'll let Cat.
Cat has hiked all 400 plus
miles, so she's seen every
inch of this, so I'll
let her handle that.
CATHERINE PATTERSON:
Well, that's a
question we love the most.
Our ambition is to hike every
mile in every park as a
culture, as a team.
So what we look at, again, from
a production point of
view is, how do we get diversity
in terms of the
geography, the types of parks,
content that we're capturing?
We're skewed a little bit on the
west right now, so we're
looking at different
parks and areas.
We look very much at parks at
risk as well, parks that are
very frequented.
So those are all things that
start to inform what our
recommendations are about where
to go next in the parks
environment.
MATT: Personal favorite?
CATHERINE PATTERSON: My
personal favorite?
Yellowstone for sure.
So far.
BRIAN MOROZ: OK.
Another question is another one
for the trails project.
In terms of risk management,
what were
your initial concerns?
Software hurdles, hardware
selection deployment, legal
issues he says regarding image
capture, but I think there's
other legal issues as well.
What if one of the hikers
broke his leg?
Did your initial risk assessment
cover the issues,
or did things come up in the
process that you had to then
scramble to cover?
CATHERINE PATTERSON: Those
are all great questions.
We again, likened it as a state
of going to war in a
positive way.
What is every variable that we
can consider, human, software,
hardware, operational, on the
ground sort of stuff?
Let's solve for it
intellectually, theoretically,
and then let's see
what happens.
So one example, we had a
wonderful camera rig, an
incredible cameraman--
Brandon is fantastic--
looking at who the
talent can be.
Who is going to be able to carry
80 pounds of freight 15
hours a day and sleep on the
rocks, is a very big question.
So all of those questions
were key.
So we tried to logically solve
as best we could, and then it
was incredibly important to have
a very strong morale and
shared intent in the team,
because when we
did encounter problems--
for example, many of us did not
have freestyle climbing
experience.
We needed to move camera rigs
off our backs and just
[INAUDIBLE]
on some freestyle climbs.
We were all terrified.
We were like, oh my god, I can't
move, hanging onto the
rocks and so on.
So those were very difficult,
and in every instance, there
were things that we
had to solve for.
In terms of risk, our legal team
was very concerned that
we were taking a bunch of people
out, that bears were
going to attack us, that people
were going to fall off
the cliff, and all of these
things were legitimate risks.
So we did three things.
We purchased unbelievably
expensive production insurance.
That was the first thing
that we did to manage
risk for the client.
Then we mandated--
and this is something
[INAUDIBLE]
has referred to earlier--
that if you intend to be in this
field team, you will be
training for three months.
That means you need to be
prepared to go out there
nutritionally, physically,
psychologically, emotionally,
on every level.
If you show up day one out there
and you're not ready,
we're going to send you home.
And it's up to you to really
want this, to be able to be
ready, and then to be able to
endure all these different
sorts of circumstances.
So there were at least three
months of very serious
training for everybody who was
in the field team, and we took
that very seriously as well.
MATT: My partner and I started
to really question what we had
done at that point.
When Cat told us that we had to
actually physically go out
and train, we knew that we are
onto something interesting,
just because I never in a
million years would have
thought being in advertising
would have required me to
actually go out and
physically train.
But it was incredibly important,
and Cat was right,
because hiking those
miles was grueling.
BRIAN MOROZ: So I hope, then,
that BASE jumping view is not
in your 2013 plan.
MATT: We'll see.
Who knows?
BRIAN MOROZ: So I have a quick
question for Josh, and then I
have a final question from
Brazil, I think is a great
question to wrap up
the entire week,
I'd like to ask everyone.
But quickly for Josh, we have
a question saying, what's up
and coming from Google
in the Maps space?
Is there any insights we can
give into what we're going to
see in 2013, or can we give any
little hints or previews,
or even things that maybe are
public but kind of quietly so
that we can talk about?
JOSH LIVNI: Well, as you
probably know, we have a habit
of not really pre-announcing so
we can keep the excitement
up, but we do have a bunch
of exciting things
I'll tell you about.
I want to just [INAUDIBLE]
earlier, though, in terms of
deciding what exciting things
to put into our API [INAUDIBLE]
platforms, we
definitely consider quite
a lot of the feedback
[INAUDIBLE].
We have a public [INAUDIBLE]
tracker, where you can list
the things that you're
interested in seeing,
requests, and we look at that
really seriously every month.
[INAUDIBLE]
answer.
But you can star the requests,
and if you have things that
you want to see and you can get
some other developers on
the same page as you, those are
much more likely to occur,
and we [INAUDIBLE]
people.
That said, we'll keep on trying
to make it as useful as
possible, and more and more
data, and all of that.
BRIAN MOROZ: So we can't give
too many hints, but you can
make requests, and
that's off of the
Developer page, you said?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, if you go
just to our [INAUDIBLE],
you'll see an [INAUDIBLE]
tracker, and in there, there's
a list of some bugs you
might see, or feature
requests you might see.
And we look at those
[INAUDIBLE]
top starred [INAUDIBLE]
requests, and that we take
pretty seriously, and
every quarter, we
answer some of those.
BRIAN MOROZ: Great, OK.
So if you guys on the call have
ideas, have thoughts, put
them in there.
And my last question,
and let's start
actually with Goodby.
And this is a very broad
question, and it's a good one
to end with.
We've only got a couple minutes,
so you're going to
have to be quick.
This comes from Emmanuel
in Brazil.
What is your concept
of creativity?
It's really easy, right?
If you were going to define
creativity, or describe your
take on what that word means,
what would it be?
GRAHAM LEWIS: I think creativity
is just time you
can look at a problem a little
bit differently than people
have previously approached it,
and just applying the most
simple solution to it without it
feeling basic, [INAUDIBLE].
And working on this project, I
kind of naturally found myself
[INAUDIBLE]
feeling simple, that I needed to
add things to it to make it
feel more interesting,
but it really just
was complicated things.
I think the key is really having
something that's very
simple and easy to communicate,
but is ultimately
this universal truth that people
can relate to on a lot
of different levels.
BRIAN MOROZ: Got it.
HANNA WITTMARK: And I think
that has been the trend.
In the beginning, when we
started [INAUDIBLE] stuff, it
was really simple, and then
when everyone started to
understand it and work with
it, everyone, like Graham
said, wanted to find new
technology and add
[? creative ?] things.
So I think going back right
now to make it even more
simple, it was hard for us.
And it was really good to have
Rich Silverstein and Anders
Gustafsson as our creative
directors because they have
been working so much longer.
So they were almost
cutting us off.
They were like, no, this
is a good idea.
Don't add more layers to it.
BRIAN MOROZ: Don't bury
it under the icing.
Very, very good answer, I think,
and I think your point
is very well taken.
It's very easy, especially when
you start playing with
technology, to go, oh, and we
can make it 3D, and then we
can make it turn inside
out, and it will glow.
Keeping it simple and
understandable and clear to
people, I think, is a great
piece of advice.
And for you guys, what
are your thoughts?
If you were going to define your
concept of creativity,
what would it be?
MATT: For me, it's
pretty simple.
It's always trying to think of
something that hasn't been
thought of before, and if it has
been thought of before and
you're going to execute it,
execute it in a way that
hasn't been executed before.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: For me,
it's using the example in
creative technology of being
very free to imagine anything.
For example, submarines and
elevators once were considered
to be preposterous notions, but
they're completely normal.
And all sorts of interesting
technology and innovation is
the result of someone saying,
you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to do this
berserk thing.
It's going to happen, and it's
going to be amazing.
So that, for me, is what
creative thinking as about.
BRIAN MOROZ: Beautiful.
All right.
So thank you guys so
much, both here in
studio and on the call.
It has been an absolute
pleasure.
Both of these projects
are fantastic.
If those of you listening would
like to learn more about
them, you can go to
creativesandbox.com, where
you'll find examples like
these and many others.
Thank you guys again so much for
being our final Hangout.
I hope those of you who have
watched from home or from the
office have enjoyed the series,
and we'd love to hear
from you and hear if you'd like
to see more of these.
Otherwise, I want to wish
everyone a wonderful weekend,
and for those in the US, a happy
Thanksgiving next week.
And we'll say adieu.
Bye, everybody.
MARGARET BRETT-KEARNS:
Thank you.
Bye bye.
CATHERINE PATTERSON: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]